Our model is really predicated on the idea
that we need large-scale change.
We need system change, not tinkering at the
margins.
We actually need to focus on a much broader
model of learning and working.
So in this model all learning should count.
It shouldn't just be the kinds of learning
that you get when you go to a traditional
learning enterprise, a college or university.
Innovation is something that we've long talked
about but today innovation is really critical
to success in the system.
We need innovation that actually focuses on
two key objectives.
The first one is time, that is the pace of
change that's happening today requires innovation
that is much more rapid than what we've seen
in the past.
So we need more like a rapid prototyping model
of innovation than what we might have had
in the past where you would do some experiments,
do some innovation and then hope for some
change.
The second important thing is scale.
The nature of the change that's required is
actually going to have to be at scale.
In other words, the innovation actually has
to be focused on the fact that it's going
to serve a large number of people – that
it's actually going to solve large-scale social
problems.
So innovation in the past and particularly
philanthropic organizations trying to support
innovation have often been focused on germinating
new ideas with the hope that at some time
these things will achieve scale.
Today, we need to be focusing on innovation
that is actually going to take place much
more rapidly and is actually going to be focused,
from the get-go, on scale.
Our objective in this work is quite simple.
First, we want to work with entrepreneurs
and discover the best ideas that are out there
that might help us achieve this large-scale
impact that we want to achieve.
The second is to elevate those ideas through
this partnership with Big Think in ways that
will give them a platform, give them visibility.
And the third is actually to work with the
entrepreneurs to achieve the scale impact
that's necessary.
And so our model here is to help uncover,
discover those big ideas, actually help to
elevate them and then work with the entrepreneurs
to achieve the scale that's needed.
So if you've got a big idea that you think
is going to address these challenges, we want
to hear from you.
We want to get your ideas and actually help
you develop them.
So under this Lumina Prize we'll actually
fly two innovators to New York for coaching
and a video interview that will allow you
to actually create a platform for this work,
for the idea that you have, to help it be
seen by millions of people.
There's a great opportunity here, not just
for Lumina Foundation and what we're trying
to achieve through our efforts as a national
leadership organization, but there's also
benefits for others.
Obviously, the entrepreneurs we want to work
with through this process are going to achieve
great benefit but so are the people who are
going to learn from this combination of what
Lumina is trying to do with these entrepreneurs
through the Big Think platform in ways that
will actually reach much broader audiences.